l on s'habitue colline en amont
vraiment
la phase et à cloyes et
dix minutes de danse latine pour gagner
des points
juliette et raphaël viennent de maisons
laffitte et évoluent ensemble depuis un
an et demi on est entre loisirs est le
haut niveau disons qu'on n'est pas on
est sur le début de ce qu'on peut
considérer comme la compétition
nationale sérieuse on va dire on en fait
suffisamment pour que ce soit plus du
loisir mais pas suffisamment pour dire
que c'est du haut niveau et qu'on passe
notre vie à spa du temps plein on a les
études arrêtées
il participe au premier grand prix de
versailles six niveaux de 8 à 70 ans
certains compétiteurs s'entraîne d'une
dizaine d'heures par semaine
seuls nous permet de maintenir notre
forme olympique
tan excellence par la danse c'est
complet le corps l'emmental plutôt que
d'aller entre la télé et le fauteuil
mieux à faire un peu de la danse à une
compétition dit classificatrice où se
mêlent danses latines américaine et dans
standards de la vase du quick step plus
de douze heures de compétition observé
par cinq juges on juge avec la technique
avec la musique avec la musicalité avec
les lignes de corps les le travail des
pieds
l'harmonie du couple la présentation du
couple la chorégraphie si elle est bien
dans l'est dans les racines des danses
c'est un rendez vous important de la
saison toutes les semaines il ya des
compétitions classificatrice et il leur
faut faire au moins six compétitions
classificatrice afin de passer dans la
série supérieure une centaine de couples
c'est affronter ce week end prochaine
compétition pour ses danseurs le 25
février à beaumont sur oise